This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many of us feel we are not leading the lives we were meant to lead, that we're not living our dreams, that life is passing us by. This sense of doubt leaves many of us feeling rudderless, confused, and stuck. I put a lot of pressure on myself to make sure that I made the exact right decision. Today we're going to explore the psychological traps we construct for ourselves that keep us from living our best lives. For many years, Christine Metzger thought she knew what she wanted to do with her life.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们许多人都觉得，我们没有过上命中注定的生活，没有实现梦想，生活正在从指尖溜走。这种怀疑感让我们许多人感到失去了方向、困惑且陷入泥潭。我给自己施加了很大的压力，以确保自己做出完全正确的决定。今天，我们将探讨我们在不知不觉中为自己设下的心理陷阱，这些陷阱阻碍了我们过上最美好的生活。克里斯蒂娜·梅茨格曾多年以为自己知道这一生想要做什么。
But after more than a decade working in education administration, she woke up one day and realized she wasn't the person she wanted to be. She didn't know exactly who she did want to be, but she was certain that that ideal version of Christine was out there. She just had to find her. She stumbled on what seemed like the perfect opportunity, developing a coaching program for teachers at a boarding school in England. She took the plunge. She quit her job, sold her belongings, and prepared to embark on her new life. I was sleeping on an arrow bed and had my three suitcases next to me.
但在教育行政部门工作了十多年后，她有一天醒来，突然意识到自己并没有成为理想中的那个人。她虽然不确定自己到底想成为谁，但她确信那个理想中的克里斯蒂娜是存在的。她只需要找到她。她偶然发现了看似完美的机遇，为英国一所寄宿学校的老师开发一个教练项目。她决定放手一搏。她辞了工作，卖掉了随身物品，准备开启她的新生活。我当时睡在一张充气床上，身旁放着三个行李箱。
I was right about to literally leave Hoboken and be on my way and I received a phone call from the folks in England saying we're really sorry but we couldn't get you a work visa. Instead of heading to England for her dream job, Christine found herself unemployed. Still in search of that ideal career, the next position she found didn't have visa issues. She would be working for the American Bible Society as liaison to the president. Even better, he had personally asked her to apply for the job. It was a long process and unfortunately in the end it turned out that the organization had a hiring freeze, and the board did not give permission to hire me, and actually eventually the president ended up leaving that company
我正准备离开霍博肯启程，这时我接到了英国那边的人打来的电话，他们说真的很抱歉，但他们没能帮我办妥工作签证。克里斯蒂娜本该去英国从事她梦想中的工作，结果却失业了。为了寻找那个理想的职业，她找到的下一份工作没有签证方面的问题。她将前往美国圣经协会担任总裁联络员。更好的是，总裁曾亲自邀请她申请这份工作。这是一个漫长的过程，不幸的是，到最后这家机构遭遇了招聘冻结，董事会没有批准招聘我，而且事实上，最终总裁也离开了那家公司
and I was left in a lurch one more time, and in a transition that I wasn't expecting or planning on. It wasn't just losing the job that bothered Christine. A nagging fear was growing at the back of her mind. She started to worry, she wasn't even on the right track. The next job came, working for a nonprofit organization in the performing arts.
我又一次陷入了困境，经历了一场我既没有预料到也没有计划过的转型。让克里斯蒂娜感到困扰的不仅仅是失业。一种挥之不去的恐惧开始在她心头滋生。她开始担心，自己甚至根本没有走在正确的轨道上。下一份工作来了，是在一家表演艺术非营利组织。
This one, she got. And then another transition came, a little earlier than I anticipated. Christine was downsized. In fact, on the day she and I talked, Christine couldn't understand it. Here she was, a smart, talented woman with years of experience, and inside, she felt like a rudderless college freshman. The pressure to discover her ideal life weighed heavy on her.
这份工作她拿到了。接着，下一次转型来了，比我预期的要早一些。克里斯蒂娜被裁员了。事实上，在她和我交谈的那天，克里斯蒂娜仍然百思不得其解。她明明是一个聪明、有才华、有着多年经验的女性，但在内心深处，她却觉得自己像个迷失方向的大学新生。探索理想生活的压力让她感到不堪重负。
And I think for most of my life, I had that sense of when I'm looking for work or if I was in a transition, I put a lot of pressure on myself to make sure that I made the exact right decision. Turns out, Christine is not alone. Lots of people feel the way she does, lost and stuck. They beat up on themselves because they not only feel they aren't getting where they want to go, they don't know where they want to go in the first place. Psychologists and self-help gurus have tried different kinds of advice for people like
我想在我大半的人生中，每当我在寻找工作或处于人生转型期时，我都会给自己施加巨大的压力，以确保自己做出绝对正确的决定。事实证明，克里斯蒂娜并不孤单。许多人和她有一样的感受，感到迷茫和卡在原地。他们严厉地苛责自己，不仅因为觉得自己没有抵达想去的地方，还因为他们压根不知道自己究竟想去哪里。心理学家和自助大师们曾为这样的人提供过各种建议
Christine, but recently we heard a new idea from an unlikely source, Silicon Valley. It turns out that engineers and designers in the tech world often face similar challenges when it comes to designing new products. How do you build something when you don't know what to build? Dave Evans used to work at Apple. One challenge he faced was in designing a new mouse.
克里斯蒂娜，但最近我们从一个意想不到的源头听到了一种新想法——硅谷。原来，科技界的工程师和设计师在设计新产品时，往往也会面临类似的挑战。当你不知道该建造什么时，又该如何去打造它呢？戴夫·埃文斯曾在苹果公司工作。他面临的挑战之一是设计一款新鼠标。
Should we have one button on the mouse or two buttons on the mouse? Dave said that he and Steve Jobs and other Apple engineers quickly figured out they really had two problems to solve. The first was to understand how people interacted with a computer to see what kind of a mouse would work for them. Before you do problem solving, you have to do problem finding. What's the right thing to be working on? To say it another way, the first challenge for the engineers was in figuring out what the problem was that they had to solve. The second challenge was to solve it.
我们应该在鼠标上设置一个按键还是两个按键？戴夫说，他和史蒂夫·乔布斯以及苹果公司的其他工程师很快发现，他们实际上需要解决两个问题。第一个是了解人们如何与计算机交互，以弄清楚哪种鼠标才适合他们。在解决问题之前，你必须先发现问题。什么是真正值得努力的方向？换句话说，工程师们面临的首要挑战是弄清楚他们究竟需要解决什么问题。第二个挑战则是解决这个问题。
Apple founder Steve Jobs thought he knew the answers, but the designers wanted to find out what was actually best for users. They built a couple of prototypes. Now a prototype isn't just a model. It's a psychological tool. We reveal the assumptions we make that are probably wrong. We get to, as we call it, sneak up on the future and involve other people with your ideas. It turned out, people preferred one button.
苹果创始人史蒂夫·乔布斯以为自己知道答案，但设计人员却想找出对用户而言真正最好的方案。他们制作了几个原型。如今，原型不仅是一个模型，它还是一个心理工具。我们借此暴露出那些可能错误的假设。正如我们所说的那样，我们得以“悄然逼近未来”，并将其他人融入到你的想法中。结果证明，人们更喜欢一个按键。
Now figuring out how to build a mouse with only one button was a complicated engineering problem. But at least now, the engineers knew where they were trying to go. Lots of people in Silicon Valley called this approach design thinking. A few years ago, Dave says he this approach design thinking. A few years ago Dave says he realized that design thinking might be useful outside the tech world too. He started teaching a course at Stanford University called designing your life. In the class Dave talks about how everyday life produces challenges that are actually made up of two entirely different kinds of problems.
现在，弄清楚如何制造一个只有一个按键的鼠标是个复杂的工程问题。但至少在当时，工程师们知道了他们努力的方向。硅谷的许多人将这种方法称为设计思维。几年前，戴夫说他认识到这种方法设计思维。几年前，戴夫说他意识到，设计思维在科技界之外也许同样大有用处。他开始在斯坦福大学教授一门名为“设计你的人生”的课程。在课堂上，戴夫谈到日常生活所带来的挑战，其实是由两种完全不同类型的问题构成的。
One kind is tame, and the other is what he calls wicket. Maintain problem is one you know how to solve. A wicket problem is one where the criteria are changing all the time, even if you come up with a solution you don't get to reuse it over and over again, the status of what you're working on changes constantly and never is stable, problems like, you know, education and poverty and your own life, or raising a kid. So, wicked problems are particularly good for the method of design thinking, because design
一种是驯服的问题，另一种则是他所说的棘手问题。所谓驯服的问题，是指你知道如何解决的问题。而棘手问题则是指那些判定标准一直在改变的问题，即便你找到了解决方案，也无法反复套用它，你所致力于解决的事物其状态在不断变化且永不稳定，比如教育、贫困、你自己的生活或是养育孩子。因此，棘手问题特别适合运用设计思维的方法，因为设计
relies on the empirical process of iterating multiple ideas with prototypes, so going out into reality, not just into your head, and trying something out. Solving these two different kinds of problems requires two different approaches. When you can't know what you're doing, you can't navigate. Like a GPS would, because you don't have a map, and you don't have all the information, you have to waive find. And waive finding means taking one step at a time, knowing something about the direction you're going, trying a few things, you know, tuning it up, and then doing it again, and doing it again.
依赖于通过原型反复迭代多个想法的实证过程，也就是走入现实，而不仅仅是在脑海中空想，去尝试一些东西。解决这两种不同类型的问题需要两种不同的方法。当你不知道自己在做什么时，你就无法导航。就像使用GPS那样，因为你没有地图，也没有所有的信息，你必须靠寻路前行。寻路意味着一次迈出一步，对行进的方向有所了解，尝试一些事情，你知道的，不断微调，然后再次尝试，不断重复。
And life is like that. Like lots of other well-educated and competent people, Christine is a good navigator. The reason she feels paralyzed is that the problem she's facing isn't one of navigation, but wayfinding. Dave's students often have the same dilemma. Everyone turns out to be pretty interested in what they're doing with their life, and nobody was given a toolkit for how to figure that out. Wayfinding isn't just about finding out where you need to go. It's about
生活正是如此。就像许多其他受过良好教育且能力出众的人一样，克里斯蒂娜是个优秀的导航员。她之所以感到瘫痪，是因为她面临的问题不是导航，而是寻路。戴夫的学生们常常面临同样的困境。每个人似乎都对他们的人生规划很感兴趣，但却没有得到过任何工具包来弄清楚该如何实现。寻路不仅是找出你需要去哪里。它还关乎
getting comfortable with the idea that you may not have just one destination. When students come to Dave and tell him they're worried they do not know what to do with their lives, he tells them, there's more than one of you in there. So there are many more than one right answer to what your life looks like. So the problem with the current approach that lots of people are taking is it starts with a wrong question. And the wrong question is, how do I figure out that one best solution to my life? There is one exclusive, unique, optimal version of me, and I'm supposed to already know it, and I'm probably already late, and how do I figure it out, and how would I know if I knew?
于适应这样一种观念：你的目的地可能不止一个。当学生们来找戴夫，告诉他他们担心自己不知道该如何度过一生时，他会告诉他们：在那里面，不止有一个你。因此，关于你的人生应该是什么样的，正确答案远不止一个。所以，许多人当前采用的方法之所以存在问题，是因为它从一个错误的问题开始。而那个错误的问题是：我该如何找出关于我人生的唯一最佳解决方案？存在一个排他的、独特的、最优版本的我，而我本就该知道它，我可能已经迟到了，我该如何找出它，如果我知道了，我又该怎么确认？
How can I be sure. And we think all those questions are the wrong questions. So this is the guy Christine turned to for help. She went to a workshop Dave was running in New York and he asked her and the other participants to do a series of different exercises to apply design thinking to whatever problem they felt stuck on. One of the exercises is what Dave calls Odyssey Planning. The principle behind the Odyssey Planning exercise
我怎么能确定呢。我们认为所有这些问题都是错误的问题。这就是克里斯蒂娜寻求帮助的对象。她去参加了戴夫在纽约举办的一个工作坊，戴夫要求她和其他参与者完成一系列不同的练习，将设计思维应用到他们感到卡壳的任何问题上。其中一项练习就是戴夫所说的“奥德赛规划”。奥德赛规划练习背后的原则
is that there isn't just one career or one life plan for any of us. Dave asks everyone to give... Three completely different variations of the next five years of your life. We've already said, we're pretty sure there are lots of you in there. There's lots of Sean Cars who could be doing, you're having a great time being a public radio host and doing really interesting work of the hidden brain. But if I suddenly said, you know,
是，对于我们任何人来说，职业或人生规划绝不只有一条。戴夫要求每个人给出……对你未来五年生活的三种完全不同的设想。我们已经说过，我们非常确凿地认为那里面有很多个你。有很多个尚卡尔，你可以去做别的事，你作为公共广播节目主持人过得很开心，在《隐藏的大脑》中做着非常有趣的工作。但如果我突然说，你知道的，
the radio world just died, Sean Cars, that's over completely. You have to do something else. Well, you wouldn't just sit on the lawn waiting for time to go by. You'd go do something else. There are other things you could do. So we have people come up with three completely different versions of themselves and then go
广播界刚刚消亡了，尚卡尔，那一切彻底结束了。你必须去做点别的。好吧，你不会只是坐在草地上干等着时间流逝。你会去做点别的。还有其他你可以做的事情。所以我们让人们构想出三个完全不同的自我版本，然后在每个版本中去尝试一些原型，这样你最终得到的将不仅仅是那一个完美的人生，而是意识到我其实可以拥有许多不同的人生，而现在我要选择我要过的那一种。
try some prototypes in each of them so that what you end up with is not just the one perfect life, but recognizing there are many lives I could have and now I'm going to choose the one that I'm going to have. It's going to be a good life, it could even be a great life, but it doesn't have to be exclusively good. It's just the good life I'm living now. Think of these life prototypes like a mouse with one button and a mouse with two buttons. Interestingly, when we do these Odyssey plans and people now have three plans in front of them that are quite different, you'd think that possibly what that does is give people even more reason
它将是美好的一生，甚至可以是很棒的一生，但它不必是唯一的完美人生。它只是我当下正在过的好日子。把这些生活原型想象成一个按键的鼠标和两个按键的鼠标。有趣的是，当我们做出这些奥德赛规划，人们面前摆着三个截然不同的规划时，你可能会觉得，这或许会让人有更多的理由
to be disappointed and dismayed, like now we know exactly what I don't get to do. I've actually written down two things I'm not gonna have time to live into. What a drag is that? And exactly the opposite occurs. What happens is when you lay out three ideas that you might be able to live into, and then
感到失望和沮丧，比如现在我们确切地知道了哪些是我无法得到的。我实际上写下了两件我没有时间去体验的事情。这多扫兴啊？但结果却完全相反。实际发生的情况是，当你列出三个你或许能够去体验的想法，然后
said, well, if I really have to pick one because I can't be three people at once, I'm going with planet. So after people have the chance to articulate to themselves what their real alternatives are, they feel better about the choice they're making. That's completely in contrast to this, are you sure you're doing the right thing? You haven't settled have you. Is this really your passion? These questions that have such an incredibly unrealistic demand of hitting this high bar,
说，好吧，如果我真的必须挑一个，因为我无法同时成为三个人，那我就选这个方案吧。因此，当人们有机会向自己明确他们真正的替代选择是什么时，他们会对自己的选择感觉更好。这完全与诸如“你确定你做的是对的事吗？你还没安定下来吧。这真的是你的热情所在吗？”这些问题形成鲜明对比。这些问题带有令人难以置信的不切实际的高标准要求，
that question you can never answer perfectly. Are you really passionate enough? I mean, who knows if they are. Are you sure that is it? The unknown competitor that you haven't had a chance to think up yet is a vicious antagonist to your peace and happiness in life. Once you realize none of us knows the future, we're making it up as we go along, so let's get really good at making it up as we go along.
那个问题你永远无法给出完美的回答。你真的足够充满热情吗？我是说，谁知道自己算不算。你确定那就是终点吗？那个你还没来得及想到的未知竞争对手，是你人生平静与幸福的残酷对头。一旦你意识到没有人知道未来，我们都是在边走边摸索，那就让我们把边走边摸索这件事做到极致吧。
In fact, let's design it as we go along. That turns out to work much more effectively. Now there are many things in our lives we just can't control. Like Christine not being able to get a work visa or being laid off from her job. People often spend years feeling frustrated about their constraints. Let's say for example you dream of being a musician, but no one will pay you to do that. Dave Evans says, that's a gravity problem. And a gravity problem is a very specific class of problem.
事实上，让我们在边走边摸索的同时去设计它。事实证明，这种做法要有效得多。在我们的生活中，确实有许多事情是我们无法控制的。比如克里斯蒂娜无法获得工作签证，或者被公司裁员。人们常常花上好几年时间对这些限制感到沮丧。比方说，你梦想成为一名音乐家，但没有人愿意付钱请你做这个。戴夫·埃文斯说，这是一个重力问题。而重力问题是一类非常特定类型的问题。
I happen to be a cyclist and I'm getting older so I'm doing that thing of putting on a little lecture weight and it's starting to bother me. So if I said, Sean Carr, I've got this terrible problem. It's gravity. It's making me crazy.
我恰好是一名骑行者，而且我正在变老，所以我开始出现那种长了一点中年发福体重的情况，这开始让我感到困扰。所以如果我说，尚卡尔，我遇到了一个可怕的问题。这就是重力。它快把我逼疯了。
It's slowing me down. It's ruining my bicycle ride. It's getting worse with time. I've got to do something about it. It's slowing me down. It's ruining my bicycle ride. It's getting worse with time. I've got to do something about it. Can you help me? And you just look at me and kind of go, no, Dave, it's not a problem. It's a gravity.
它拖慢了我的速度。它毁了我的骑行。而且随着时间推移越来越严重。我必须得做点什么。它拖慢了我的速度。它毁了我的骑行。而且随着时间推移越来越严重。我必须得做点什么。你能帮帮我吗？而你只是看着我，然后大概会说，不，戴夫，这不是个问题。这是重力。
What do you want me to do? But a lot of people are in fact dealing with a problem that's just like gravity. Again, design is oriented to action. One of our mindsets is biased to action. One of our minds it's as biased to action. When it out do something, which means if you can't do anything about it, if it's not actionable, it's not a problem. It's a circumstance. And a lot of people have a problem that isn't a problem. It's just
你希望我怎么做？但实际上，许多人正在处理的问题恰恰就像重力一样。同样的，设计是以行动为导向的。我们的心态之一就是以行动为导向。我们的心态之一就是以行动为导向。当无事可做时，这意味着如果你对此无能为力，如果它是不可采取行动的，那它就不是一个问题。它只是一种现状。许多人遇到的问题根本不是问题。它只是
a circumstance. So let's say the problem is you can't make any money as a professional musician. Unless you're in the top 1 1 1 1% which at now that I'm 37 years old and frankly only nominally talented at doing this thing, my chances of attaining are about zero. That's not a problem. That's a fact. People get stuck on the wrong person and how can I make a living and keep my mortgage paid by being a musician?
一种现状。所以假设问题是你作为一名专业音乐家赚不到钱。除非你跻身前1%——现在我37岁了，坦白讲，在这件事上我也只有名义上的才华，我达成这一目标的几率大约为零。这不是一个问题。这是一个事实。人们纠缠于错误的事情，比如我该如何靠当音乐家谋生并付清房贷？
That is not an actionable problem. Once you accept your gravity problem, as in fact, not a problem, but a circumstance, maybe a difficult one, maybe a heartbreaking one, but once you realize it's just a fact, you free yourself to go do something you can do. So once I've decided, oh, I'm never going to be able to make this income as a musician. That's not a problem. It's just an awful fact. Now what do I do? Well, I have two different paths that I can go right off the bed. I can say, great, how can I learn how to live on $15,000 a year and feed my family of three? How can I learn how to live on $15,000 a year and feed my family of three, obviously not in this house, while being a rising-starving musician?
那不是一个可付诸行动的问题。一旦你接受了你的重力问题，事实上它不是一个问题，而是一种现状，也许是一个艰难的现状，也许是一个令人心碎的现状，但一旦你意识到它只是一个事实，你就解放了自己，可以去做你能做的事情。所以一旦我下定决心，哦，我永远无法作为一名音乐家赚取这笔收入。那不是一个问题。这只是一个糟糕的事实。现在我该怎么办？好吧，我马上就有两条不同的道路可以走。我可以大声说，太棒了，我该如何学会每年靠15,000美元生活并养活三口之家？我该如何学会每年靠15,000美元生活并养活三口之家，显然不能住在目前的这栋房子里，同时还要做一个苦苦挣扎的音乐新兴之星？
And I can actually figure out how to do that. I know people who successfully do. Or I could ask the question, since I'm never going to get to be a professional musician, how can I craft a lifestyle that keeps my income going while making my application. The thing I do for love, not money, called music, as satisfying as possible. That's a life I could design. This is the heart of design thinking. It isn't about becoming your perfect self. It's about looking very honestly at your circumstances and asking what room you have to maneuver.
我其实可以弄清楚如何做到这一点。我认识成功做到这一点的人。或者我可以提出这样的问题：既然我永远无法成为一名专业音乐家，我该如何精心设计一种生活方式，在维持收入的同时，让我的音乐创作——我为之付出爱而非金钱的事情——尽可能地令人满足。那是我可以设计的生活。这就是设计思维的核心。它不是关于变成最完美的自己。而是关于极其诚实地审视你的现状，并问问自己还有多少可以回旋的空间。
Think about those designers in Silicon Valley. They're always releasing programs in beta. The idea is you try something very practical and very doable, something that you can do quickly, send it out into the world, and then learn from how it performs. You come back, iterate, and then go back to the world again. This is Dave's idea about how you should design your life. Rather than sitting around thinking about what would be ideal, try a series of experiments, learn from them. And here's the important thing.
想想硅谷的那些设计师。他们总是在发布测试版程序。这个想法是，你尝试一些非常实用且切实可行的事情，一些你可以迅速完成的事情，将其推向世界，然后从中了解它的表现。你回来，进行迭代，然后再次进入现实世界。这就是戴夫关于你应当如何设计人生的理念。与其坐在那里空想什么才是理想状态，不如去进行一系列的实验，并从中汲取教训。这里最重要的一点是：
Keep doing this indefinitely. There is no perfect you, but there's probably a better you that is achievable. Designers aren't necessarily more creative than everybody else, but they are better at getting unstuck. Christine Metzger says this idea really helped her think about her problem differently. There is not just one right job for you, and I think for most of my life I had that sense of when I'm looking for work or if I was in a transition, I put a lot of pressure on myself to make sure that I made the exact right decision. And we talked in the class about how there's so much potential in each person and you have so many different skills and talents in the way you're wired
将这件事无限期地做下去。世界上没有最完美的你，但很可能有一个可以实现的、更好的你。设计师不一定比其他人更有创意，但他们更擅长摆脱困境。克里斯蒂娜·梅茨格表示，这个想法确实帮助她以不同的方式思考自己的问题。世界上并没有唯一适合你的完美工作，我想在我大半的人生中，每当我在寻找工作或处于人生转型期时，我都会给自己施加巨大的压力，以确保自己做出绝对正确的决定。我们在课上讨论过，每个人体内都蕴含着如此巨大的潜能，你拥有如此之多的不同技能和天赋，这取决于你的天性
that there's not just one thing that you can do, but there are many. Abandoning the idea of finding her idea life was liberating. I really like this idea with design thinking about what can I do in the next two weeks that can give me some new information. But that just seemed really doable. And I think that's important when you're trying to make decisions or get unstuck that you're not thinking about, oh, I just have to figure everything out perfectly. But in fact, I liked what he said about.
因此，你能够做的事绝不只有一件，而是有很多件。放弃寻找理想生活的念头是一种解放。我真的很喜欢设计思维中关于“我在接下来的两周里能做些什么来获取一些新信息”的想法。这听起来真的很切实可行。我想，当你试图做出决定或摆脱困境时，这一点很重要，那就是你不要去想，哦，我必须把一切都完美地搞清楚。事实上，我很喜欢他所说的话。
With design thinking, your goal is to fail early and often. When we come back, we look at another example of design thinking. A writer who felt she'd lost her way, but then found a new path forward. I was raised, you know, right every day, right 1500 words a day, go to graduate school, rewrite, rewrite, rewrite,
通过设计思维，你的目标是尽早且频繁地失败。稍后回来，我们将探讨设计思维的另一个例子。一位曾觉得自己迷失了方向，但随后找到了前进新道路的作家。我受到的教育是，你知道的，每天写作，一天写1500字，去读研究生，重写、重写、重写，
and this was never a way to write, that was given to me, I really did just sort of make it up. Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We started today with Christine Metzkar, who sought out design thinking to help her get unstuck. Next, we'll hear from someone who exemplified design thinking without even knowing it. Our producer Maggie Penman has the story. Helen Ellis grew up in Tuscallusa, Alabama, dreaming of being a writer.
而这从来都不是一种固定的写作方式，它不是别人赋予我的，我真的是凭感觉自己摸索出来的。请继续收听。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们今天从寻求设计思维帮助以摆脱困境的克里斯蒂娜·梅茨格开始。接下来，我们将听到一位在不知不觉中践行了设计思维的人的故事。我们的制作人玛吉·彭曼带来了这个报道。海伦·埃利斯在阿拉巴马州塔斯卡卢萨长大，梦想着成为一名作家。
In her mind, being a serious writer, meant moving to New York. So at 22 years old, that's what she did. I came to New York dressed in Alabama's finest at the time, which was Talbot's, a full-planned ankle length skirt and turtle neck. And I went from publishing, has to publishing, I was trying to get a job, and publishing, no one would hire me, and I ended up getting a job at Talbotts.
在她看来，成为一名严肃的作家意味着搬到纽约。所以在22岁那年，她就这样做了。我穿着阿拉巴马州当时最棒的服饰来到纽约，那是Talbots品牌的服装，一身及踝长裙加高领毛衣。我一家接一家地跑出版社，我当时在找工作，但在出版界，没有人愿意雇佣我，最后我反而在Talbots找到了一份工作。
Helen worked in retail for a few years, and then as a secretary, but she kept her eyes on her goal. Finally, she got her big break. She got into NYU's creative writing program off the wait list, and started writing her first novel. And it was like a dream. I came out of graduate school, I sold the book within a year, it was a nice sum of money, it did very well. Helen was just 29, she was living in Manhattan, and she was a published author. She had arrived.
海伦做过几年零售，后来又当过秘书，但她始终紧盯着自己的目标。最终，她迎来了重大突破。她通过候补名单进入了纽约大学的创意写作专业，并开始创作她的第一部小说。那感觉就像一场梦。我刚从研究生院毕业，不到一年就把书卖了，版权费是一笔相当可观的数字，书也卖得非常好。海伦当时只有29岁，住在曼哈顿，是一位已出版作品的作家。她成功了。
She immediately started working on her next book. But no one wanted to publish it. I think it was about a poker play serial killer. She wrote another book about a 19th century prostitute in Mississippi. Nobody wanted to publish that either. She decided the problem was that she wasn't focusing enough on writing, so she quit her day job and doubled down on being a full-time writer. She wrote another book, and again, couldn't get it published.
她立即开始创作下一本书。但没有人愿意出版它。我想那是一本关于扑克牌连环杀手的小说。她又写了一本关于密西西比州19世纪妓女的书。同样没有人愿意出版。她认定问题出在自己没有把足够多的精力放在写作上，于是她辞掉了正职工作，全身心投入到全职写作中。她写了另一本书，结果依然无法出版。
I just didn't write anything good enough. Helen put the manuscripts away in a drawer. And then I quit. And nobody cared. Honestly, all that happens is you put on 10 pounds. Helen felt like a failure. Like, maybe she wasn't meant to be a writer after all. Having quit her day job and now writing too, empty days stretched out before her. But Helen is not the kind of person who was content to do nothing. As it turns out, Helen likes to cook and clean and decorate, so she became, in her words, a housewife. I'm a housewife.
我只是写不出足够好的东西。海伦把手稿收进抽屉里。然后我辞职了。没人会在乎。老实说，唯一发生的变化是你重了10磅。海伦觉得自己是个失败者。也许她根本就不是一块当作家的料。既然辞去了正职又不写了，空虚的日子在她面前无限延伸。但海伦并不是那种甘愿无所事事的人。事实证明，海伦喜欢做饭、打扫卫生和搞装修，于是按照她自己的话说，她成了一名家庭主妇。我是一名家庭主妇。
And through herself into it. It's art, yeah, it really is. Helen may not have used this word to describe what she was doing, but she was wayfinding. She turned her entire Manhattan apartment into a masterpiece of whimsy. She put up flamingo wallpaper in the entryway and had a little flamingo painted on the next wall, as if he escaped the wallpaper and strutted around the corner. Sort of a tribute to flamingos in the front yard where I grew up.
并且全身心投入其中。这是一种艺术，是的，真的如此。海伦或许没有用这个词来形容她正在做的事情，但她确实在寻路。她把整个曼哈顿的公寓变成了一件异想天开的杰作。她在玄关贴上了火烈鸟壁纸，还在相邻的墙上画了一只小火烈鸟，仿佛它从壁纸里逃出来，正昂首阔步地拐过街角。某种程度上，这是对我在那里长大的前院里的火烈鸟的一种致敬。
She got the most amazing refrigerator. It's bright orange and looks like something straight off the set of madmen. When I went to visit her, it was one of the first things I noticed. I love the fridge. If my people have dream jewelry and I had a dream fridge. It was perfect. And if you care to poke around in her medicine cabinet, which Helen insists everyone does,
她买到了最棒的冰箱。它是亮橘色的，看起来就像直接从《广告狂人》剧组里搬出来的一样。我去看望她时，这是我注意到的第一件事。我爱死这个冰箱了。如果说别人有梦想珠宝，那我则拥有梦想冰箱。它完美极了。如果你有兴趣翻翻她的医药箱——海伦坚持每个人都要这么做，
you'll find little bits of humor and color there too. Well, there's a gnome. There's a 1940's kitty cat planter filled with cotton balls, and it's of course arranged by color. Of course. But even as she collected art and records and antiques, she was sometimes reminded of the dream she had given up. And I would go places with my husband and people would ask me, what do you do? And I would say, honestly, I'm a housewife.
你也会在那里发现一些幽默感和小色彩。好吧，里面有个侏儒。还有一个装满棉球的1940年代小猫花盆，当然，它们是按颜色排列的。当然啦。但即便是在她收集艺术品、唱片和古董的过程中，她有时还是会被提醒想起那个她已经放弃的梦想。我和丈夫去某些地方时，人们会问我，你是做什么工作的？而我会说，老实说，我是个家庭主妇。
And the next question they would ask, if there was another question, was, what do you do all day? After getting that question one too many times, If there was another question, was, what do you do all day? After getting that question one too many times, Helen came up with an answer in the form of a snarky Twitter account. She called it, what I do all day. I just started tweeting about my life, funny little things, and as I gained more followers, I gained confidence again.
他们接着会问的下一个问题——如果还有下一个问题的话，那就是，你整天都做些什么？在听到这个问题太多次之后——如果还有下一个问题的话，那就是，你整天都做些什么？在听到这个问题太多次之后，海伦通过一个尖酸刻薄的推特账号想出了一个答案。她给它取名为“我整天都在干嘛”。我开始在推特上发一些关于我生活的推文，一些有趣的小事，随着粉丝越来越多，我又重新获得了自信。
Helen's Twitter persona is like a 1950s housewife on steroids. She tweets things like, women doubt, dust. Or my idea of crushing it is making a graham crack or crust. Her Twitter account also includes plenty of translation of what Helen calls Southern Lady Code, which she describes as, If you don't have something nice to say, say something that's so nice in a nice way. Like, her Instagram is very curated.
海伦的推特人设就像是个打了鸡血的1950年代家庭主妇。她会发一些诸如“女人质疑，掸尘”之类的推文。或者“我概念中的大获成功就是做个全麦饼干底”。她的推特账号还包含了对海伦所谓的“南方淑女密码”的大量翻译，她将之描述为：如果你没有好听的话要说，那就用动听的方式说些好听的话。比如，她的Instagram非常精心策划。
It's Southern Lady Code for, she is a hotter miss, then spaghetti and meatballs and a clothes dryer. Her Twitter account became increasingly popular. People loved her self-deprecating humor and related to the daily struggles of cooking and cleaning and laundry. And there was another benefit too. Little by little, tweaked by Tweet,
那是南方淑女密码，意思是：她是个糟糕透顶的失败者，比意面肉丸配烘干机还要乱七八糟。她的推特账号越来越受欢迎。人们喜爱她那自嘲式的幽默，并对烹饪、打扫和洗衣的日常生活挣扎感同身受。这也带来了另一个好处。渐渐地，一条推特接一条推特，
she was writing again, 140 characters at a time. It got me unstuck. It really did. Even better, her followers gave her instant feedback, telling her which ideas were funny and which jokes fell flat. I found that Twitter was an excellent editor, so if I tweeted something and it wasn't retweeted in say 20 minutes, it's deleted.
她又开始写作了，每次以140个字符为限。这让我摆脱了困境。真的如此。更好的是，她的粉丝们给了她即时反馈，告诉她哪些想法很有趣，哪些笑话冷场了。我发现推特是一个极好的编辑，所以如果我发了一条推特，比如在20分钟内没有被转发，我就会把它删掉。
Tweeting allowed Helen to just throw something out there. See if it stuck. In the language of design thinking, she was prototyping. I had gone about writing in a very structured, traditional way for my entire life, writing 15-hundred words a day, going to graduate school, having a full-time job, writing in the morning. If this doesn't work, write another one.
发推特让海伦能够随手抛出一个想法。看看它是否奏效。用设计思维的语言来说，她是在进行原型测试。我一辈子都在以一种高度结构化、传统的方式写作，一天写1500字，去读研究生，有一份全职工作，在早晨写作。如果这个不行，就写另一本。
If this doesn't work, write another one in the same way. And I think it was, well I know it was breaking that pattern that helped me find my voice again. When she had enough tweets to fill a book or even two, she printed them all out to see what was there. A few themes emerged. Love and marriage, dinner parties, cutting commentary about housework, her neighbors, and her two cats. So she did something she had been trying to do for years. She wrote another book and got it published. A book of short stories inspired by her tweets. It was called American Housewife.
如果这个不行，就用同样的方式再写一本。我认为——我知道正是打破这种模式帮助我重新找回了自己的声音。当她积累了足以装满一本书甚至两书的推文时，她把它们全部打印出来，看看里面都有什么。几个主题浮现出来：爱情与婚姻、晚宴、关于家务的尖锐评论、邻居以及她的两只猫。于是她做了一件她多年来一直想做的事。她写了另一本书并成功出版。那是一本受她推特启发而创作的短篇小说集。书名叫《美国主妇》。
After years of trying to write books that I thought other people would want to read that were never published, I thought, maybe, I'll write what I know. I had 10 years under my belt and I thought, well, there is nothing more unpredictable than a woman left alone in her home all day long. Let's explore that.
在尝试了多年那些我认为别人会想读却从未能出版的书籍之后，我想，也许，我会写我所了解的东西。我有了十年的积累，我想，好吧，世上再没有什么比一个整天独自呆在家里的女人更难以预测的了。让我们来探索一下吧。
The first story in the collection is called What I Do All Day. And that story is made up probably 96% of tweets that I tweeted over three years and then coupled together. And people always say, every other line is just a killer. And it's because Twitter was my editor, if it's not retweeted, it's deleted. So every sentence in that story was retweeted or applauded or approved.
合集中的第一篇故事名叫《我整天都在干嘛》。那个故事大概96%的内容都是我过去三年里发过的推特，然后拼凑在一起的。人们总说，里面的每一两行都是金句。这是因为推特就是我的编辑，如果没有被转发，就会被删掉。所以那个故事里的每一个句子都曾被转发、喝彩或认可。
And it was just this new way to write. When Helen was 29 and had just published a successful literary novel, she felt tremendous pressure to write the perfect second book. But now, in her 40s, having failed so many times, she looks at things differently. I mean, one of the nice things about the failure and saying that I was a housewife and having the anonymous account was nobody knew it was me, nobody was watching, there were absolutely no expectations, and it really freed me and I had been able to, as you know, today keep hold of that. Her second book has done very well, but if it hadn't, I really would have been fine.
这只是一种全新的写作方式。海伦29岁时刚刚出版了一部成功的文学小说，她感到了巨大的压力，非要写出完美的第二本书。但现在，到了40多岁，经历了这么多次失败后，她对事情有了不同的看法。我是说，失败的好处之一，以及承认自己是个家庭主妇并拥有这个匿名账号的好处在于，没有人知道我是谁，没有人盯着，绝对没有任何期望，这真的解放了我，正如你所知，我今天能够一直保持这种心态。她的第二本书卖得很好，但如果没有的话，我也真的会过得很好。
So, um, and it was 15 years between books, I really don't feel the pressure until I'm 60. Helen Ellis, speaking with producer Maggie Pendman. Many of us feel stuck. Stuck at work, stuck in the wrong city, stuck in life. When that happens, we often end up asking ourselves, what should I do? Where should I live? What's my ideal life?
所以，嗯，两本书之间隔了15年，在我60岁之前，我真的感受不到什么压力。海伦·埃利斯在与制作人玛吉·彭曼交谈。我们许多人都感到卡在原地。困在工作中，困在错误的城市里，困在生活中。当这种情况发生时，我们最终往往会问自己：我该做什么？我该住在哪里？我理想的生活是什么样的？
It turns out these normal questions are counterproductive to getting us unstuck. They place an unbearable pressure on us, the pressure to know how things are supposed to turn out. The next time that happens to you, think of your life, the way a designer at a tech company, things of a new product. You don't quite know what you want to build. Just for fun, you come up with a prototype, then a second and a third. You pay attention to whether you enjoy building one kind of prototype or another.
事实证明，这些常规问题对我们摆脱困境适得其反。它们给我们施加了无法承受的压力，即必须知道事情将如何发展的压力。下一次当你遇到这种情况时，试着用科技公司设计师看待新产品的方式来思考你的人生。你并不完全清楚自己想打造什么。只是为了好玩，你先做一个原型，然后是第二个和第三个。你留意自己是更享受打造某一种原型还是另一种。
You listen to feedback from others. You go back to the drawing board and try again. When someone asks you, yours later, how you knew what you wanted to be, you can tell them, honestly, I didn't. This week's episode was produced by Maggie Penman, edited by Jenny Schmidt and Tara Boyle. Our team also includes Renee Clar, who does great videos and illustrations for our Facebook and Twitter accounts. If you like this episode, please share it with a friend who doesn't know about our show
你倾听来自他人的反馈。你回到图纸前重新尝试。当多年后有人问你，你是怎么知道自己想成为什么样的人时，你可以诚实地告诉他们：老实说，我不知道。本周的节目由玛吉·彭曼制作，珍妮·施密特和塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队还包括蕾妮·克拉尔，她为我们的Facebook和Twitter账号制作了精彩的视频和插图。如果你喜欢本期节目，请把它分享给一位还不知道我们节目的朋友，
and tell us who you've tapped on social media. We always want more people to discover the show. Our unsung hero this week is Cara Tallow. Cara works at Morning Edition and played a vital role in developing Hidden Brain on Public Radio. Besides being a very good journalist, she also has superpowers when it comes to juggling last minute scheduling changes. She has the patience of a saint and regularly needs it.
并在社交媒体上告诉我们你标记了谁。我们总是希望更多人发现这个节目。我们本周的幕后英雄是卡拉·塔洛。卡拉在《早间新闻》工作，在公共广播中开发《隐藏的大脑》的过程中发挥了至关重要的作用。除了是一位优秀的记者外，她在应付最后一刻的排期变更时还拥有超能力。她有着圣人般的耐心，而且经常需要用到这种耐心。
I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。